روح مقاتلينا الموجودين في غزة ونحن
وطبعا نحن نتحدث عن الجرحى والمصابين في الجسد
ولكن من الناس من يتألم في نفسه التي جرحت إلى الأبد
والليلة الماضية كانت حدثا صعبا للغاية
يمكن أن تنتهي كذلك
باسون، مقاتل في لواء المظليين الذي خرج لتجديد نشاطه
بعد لواء المظليين هو اللواء الذي كان
أطول وقت في الداخل ولم يخرج أيضًا
في وقف إطلاق النار
بقسوة، يخرج الجميع للانتعاش في المنشأة
ملجأ جمعية الجندي في عسقلان وهو
كان ينام هناك ليلاً مع أصدقائه من الوحدة
من المظليين
في الغرفة يستيقظ في منتصف الليل من كابوس
يعتقد أنه في غزة، وربما يعتقد أنه محاصر
في الحبال يمسك السلاح ويبدأ في الرؤية
وضربت الكرات الحائط لحسن الحظ في الغالب
كما أصيب عدد من أصدقائه بجروح طفيفة جراء الشظايا
كان إطلاق النار حدثًا كان من الممكن أن ينتهي بكارثة
صحيح، أعتقد أن هناك تعتيمًا كبيرًا جدًا
ليقوم به القادة
لديهم دعوات سوداء وضغوط لفقدان كل ما هم عليه
الاجتياز هو واجب القائد، أذكرك
أن قادة المظليين هؤلاء وصلوا إلى النهاية أيضًا
شباب صغار جدًا يبلغون من العمر 22 عامًا وهم يخسرون
للشباب 18 سنة